very special guest as we have chess
grandmaster jeffrey young everybody's
friend
to join us
uh good afternoon jeffrey nice to see
you
hey happy to be here guys yeah uh first
question
what do you think of the candidates
uh well i mean i have to say it's been
really exciting so far
i thought
in general i i think everyone
probably hopes that you know everyone
shows their best and
we get this sort of tournament where
all kinds of results are are possible
and
i guess that is somewhat true but uh in
this case maybe
a nepo in particular is kind of
distancing himself so
right now
obviously the games have been very
exciting but i just hope that uh
things sort of get get closer you know
yeah is it surprising to you that
dingler in with all of his experience
with his
great rating has performed
poorly
yeah i mean you definitely have your
fair share of surprises so far i think
the biggest factor for being um
okay outside of maybe
there is obviously the
the reason that you know he hasn't
played much
top level uh classical chess recently
like he had to play these few
tournaments before just to get in maybe
didn't really have the i mean this type
of opposition for sure not
and then the other thing is more mental
which is he didn't actually have
somebody coming from china with him
right and i'm sure yesterday you can
speak about this uh yourself but to have
somebody with you is it's just i mean
it's it's vital honestly so i think not
having somebody made it really tough for
him of course
i have yes
about you
so when is your next big tournament
actually i'm flying to philadelphia on
wednesday to play in the world open so
wonderful pretty soon yeah nice have you
you've won the world open in the past
jeffrey
uh technically i guess i i tied with
liam one year i think uh in 2019 but he
he beat me in the in the playoffs soon
[Music]
okay alejandro jump in uh
quiz the x factor absolutely jeffrey
good to have you on camera a young man
i've known for many many years as we
played in the dallas chess club back in
the day jeffrey it seems like you are
almost there you're making that step to
start thinking about fighting for those
candidate spots what do you think is
making the difference between these high
2600s low 27s and these guys
yeah
it's a very good question um i wish i
could give you
a definitive answer but
i i think i've honestly i honestly
believe that the margins between
all these levels which you which you've
just said are very small but
i think just certain things that
um
like the better players will do
differently
i would highlight the
resistance and like the the level of
defense uh when it gets higher
and one evident example is
is right here in this tournament where i
think if you look at farouja
specifically um he dominated the
grand swiss and also the uh european
team championships by
beating up on these you know 2600 level
players and obviously he played very
well in those games but
when it was time to you know face off
against these uh
you know upper
upper class guys it was uh much much
more difficult so i think that's kind of
the the big biggest uh hurdle
good jeffrey if i can
today it says fight for first it's all
it's do or die for fabi
i'm gonna give you the current position
i'm sure you've been following the game
in real time we've just seen this move
knight a6 to c5 by
jan
so 97
check as well as bishop
f1
are is are both on fabi's agenda the
bishop hitting the knight on d6 take us
through your thought process if you were
in fabie shoes
and you felt that this was a must-win
game
uh number one
you think
you you think you're better but do you
think you're winning
yeah first of all i want to say that
fabi he's done very well to to get here
i think right uh i i actually i just
wanna when i i've been by far the most
impressed with fabi's opening prep
coming in um compared to everybody else
like even yesterday's game i think he
had very nice prep and
uh actually i'm sorry to sort of uh
steer away from the question but i'm
just so curious that
yesterday if you remember uh when he
carried blitzed out that move knight g3
right i was sure it was like a bluff or
some kind of mix-up but
after i mean i watched the car's
interview i'm not so sure so what
what did you make of that
yeah we talked about that earlier too
was that uh
knight g3 and the two the two minor
pieces versus the rook uh from fabi's
game
yesterday and
the idea was that um
hikaru said that wasn't actually his
preparation that it was some kind of a
finger slip he intended something else
it worked out really well but
when we saw the position after c4
we were actually impressed by
ikaru's preparation you're saying you
were impressed
by fobbies
yeah yeah because i think
i mean i think you're highlighting the
critical moment there if
when he played c4 and hikaru wait i mean
he found this brilliant idea knight h1
then
he really turned the tables in it became
really uh i mean just tough for black
but if he had gone e4 maybe fabi would
be in the driver's seat instead of c4
right
that was a huge discussion that we had
yesterday too between e4 and c4 and
that's you know giving up the d4 squared
does it actually pay off or is it just
going to be torture for the game but
also we were thinking about e4 but we
got dissuaded because
alejandro was showing as knight g5
and there was this knight takes e4 and
there was this crazy lines with queen d1
and it still felt like hikaru
would be doing the pushing
yeah i'm sure it's it's up for debate it
was just a really really sharp position
um
okay you did a great job at docking the
question congratulations
back to the focus what what what do you
think you you got to win with with white
i'm putting you in fobby shoes are you
playing bishop f1 you're playing 97 what
you're doing jeffrey come on
i think intuitively i would definitely
feel like bishop f1 is more natural okay
but at the same time i'm trying to
understand like 97 is a king f7 or
what's going on there
right it's kind of forced because if
king gets it then there's not really
much i mean black is not really
attacking anything white can just
develop rook d1
yeah
i see okay and you have just
many threats yep
we were thinking
97 king f7 bishop drops back
to f1
and
the main move alejandro jump in on this
one yeah knight c8 is a
necessity because the moves rook take e7
bishop takes d6 leads into variations
that don't really favor black there's so
many lines in which the move rook d1 is
impossible to meet right you can't move
the knight from c5 square because either
knight takes f5 or bishop c4 check will
pick up something
so in this particular position bishop c4
anyway
right which already looks terrifying of
course
now knight h takes f5 as another move
instead of bishop c4 that also needs to
be considered also gives white an
advantage but bishop c4 check is the
line that we were looking at and bishop
e6
take that with the rook keep the
initiative alive
rook takes knight takes knight h takes
f5 and what do you make of these apples
wow
come on you gotta win dude you gotta win
yeah this is it this is your time to
shine
i guess like so bishop to rookie oh wait
no actually it
looks pretty good for white i have to
say this
exactly that was our impression as well
that uh
fabi was in the the driver's seat here
and yeah i also had my own on the hikaru
game okay
we'll jump to that one
uh
we thought that well frankly that uh
that hikaru wasn't going to get any
compensation he did play
the awfully slow king h8
h6
ponderously slow
but he's gotten an f5 your thoughts
about hikaru and ikaru
he's knocking he's he's at the back door
that he's knocking trying to get in he
needs to put together some wins do you
think hikaro can can do that jeffrey
yeah you're right he does uh
i think he he he is he's trying in a
good way like with kha that was
for sure mandatory and the good news for
him is i think this is the right
opponent to sort of
you know
just throw the kitchen sink against
because raja has been very risk-averse
in the tournament right uh thus far so
if he sees i mean he's the most likely
guy to see ghosts here but that being
said
i'm not sure if if this will pan out
let's see i guess
after f5
jeffrey uh we want to thank you very
much for taking time out of your day to
join us it's always good to see you
and as the fourth of july comes up i
hope you have a real opportunity to
celebrate
by winning the world open
world open
all right thank you
thank you thank you it was a pleasure
absolutely
and um jeffrey makes a point
dorset